we're rolling just like perfect for
holidays all this season throughout and
every kind of date afterwards and before
and in between I don't know hey guys I'm
Abby Shar welcome to Abby's kitchen for
my Canadian viewers out there I hope you
had an amazing Thanksgiving weekend
obviously there's so much to be thankful
for this year and I got out of
Thanksgiving feeling overwhelmingly
lethargic I was like stuffed to the brim
I was feeling a little bit sick brother
because I ate too much and usually those
sensations kind of start to fizzle off
few hours later when you wake up from
the carb coma but this one this year I
was sick all Monday I was sick all
Tuesday and Here I am feeling that same
way here on Wednesday and that got me
thinking maybe this year it's not the
food baby maybe it's the real baby see
what I did there yeah yeah food baby
real baby food baby real baby folks we
are having a baby so this is something
that my partner and I have wanted for a
long time so there is nothing we are
more thankful for this holiday season
this is really new territory for me but
I'm really excited to bring you guys
along so we're gonna be talking about
you know my body changing and pregnancy
cravings and morning sickness the fun
doesn't stop folks today I'm gonna share
one of my favorite recipes that has
really helped me get through the first
trimester this is my vegan stuffed
butternut squash and cashew shells with
a really yummy creamy cashew and staged
sauce it is perfect for any of the
holidays that are coming up of course
but also really just for entertaining or
stuff in your face at midnight because
you're having a major craving trust me I
know all right guys so let's do this
I had some shell passed it to a pot of
boiling salted water and cooked them
according to the directions on the path
now we prepare the filling I add some
soaked cashews to a food processor and
get them going along with some almond
milk some lemon juice and some cooked
butternut squash and I puree everything
together until it's creamy and smooth
then I add some olive oil to a pan along
some garlic and sage give that a good
stir until everything starts to cook
then I add in a ton of spinach and let
it wilt down before adding it to the
butternut squash and cashew filling I
also add in some vegan cheese and give
it a good stir season it with some
pepper and salt and then I stream my
pasta out now let's make sauce I add my
soaked cashews to the food processor
along with some almond milk and some
lemon juice and I pureed that until it's
nice and smooth then I add some more
olive oil to a pan along with some
garlic and some more sage give it a good
saute and then add in the creamy cashew
mixture stir it around and add in some
maple syrup some cinnamon pepper and
salt and let it bubble away now we stuff
the shelves I put all of the shells into
a nice big casserole dish and I transfer
my filling into a piping bag to make it
easier to fill them then I squeeze it
into each little shell
top the whole thing off with some more
vegan cheese pop it into a 375-degree
oven for 20 to 25 minutes and look at
that sauce those bad boys up and enjoy
well guys this stuffed shell right here
is gonna get back to eating those
amazing stuffed shells
if you loved this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below some of your favorite fall recipes
for eating with your friends and family
or for feeding your baby I want to know
some of your amazing
pregnancy friendly recipes subscribe to
the channel and I will see you next time
on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]